Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ellie from
Seattle. Ellie, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, thanks for taking
my call. Pleasure. I. I feel like with
the don't say gay, the legislation that it
just passed in Florida and there's a number
of like anti-trans bills across the country, I
feel like we're watching a very slow train wreck
and I want to know how do we stop it?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would say it's not
even necessarily that slow,
and it's all being driven by
local elected officials and like we've
been saying for a very long time.
You have to control governorships and state
senates and state legislatures. And when you
don't, these are the types of things that happen.
And the danger level is exacerbated because we
know that we have one of the most conservative
Supreme Courts in a very, very long time.
Even if Judge Jackson replaces Stephen Breyer,
it doesn't change the balance of the court. It's
still a very conservative court. And so there's
the additional risk that one or two states
will have some of these bills challenged all the
way up to the Supreme Court and upheld. And then
it's going to be open season in every red state.
So I think this is a this is the combination of
about half a dozen different failures.
Speaker 4: Yeah, and we're probably
looking at Roe go into the Supreme Court, too.
Speaker 1: Maybe so, maybe so. Yeah. Yeah, that's
not. It's not at all impos. It's not completely
plausible that that will happen. And you know,
I mean, I can't there's no one thing, Ali,
that there is to blame for this. You know,
it's like, yes, Democrats have not done enough at
the state level. Yes, all these different things.
But also remember Ali, the people in 2016 who said
Supreme Court picks. I don't care. I don't care
whether it's Trump and Hillary. We would not be in
this situation right now. We're Hillary Clinton,
the winner in 2016. And had Hillary Clinton
been able to select some Supreme Court justices,
we just wouldn't be in this situation.
Speaker 4: Yeah, absolutely. Is there, I mean,
you said it's not even necessarily a
slow train wreck, is there anything
that we can do to mitigate it?
Speaker 1: We are. I mean, listen,
there's elections in November. What can
be done at the state level in November?
How many governorships can can be taken from
Republicans? How many legislatures or state
senates can be taken from Republicans?
And I don't know the answer. I don't have
the data in front of me, but it's not just about
Senate and House of Representatives. Nationally,
we've got to be doing better at the state level,
and it's just it's embarrassing, quite frankly.
Speaker 4: Absolutely. Well, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: Ellie from Seattle, thank you
so much for the call. A disturbing
situation or disturbing situation?